gary johnson and william weld boat are a
ticket that we can take to the american
people when I saw him speaking I saw
someone who was genuine who wasn't
interested in seizing power or any of
that other stuff you feel like you're
connecting with somebody it doesn't feel
like you're talking to a politician
there's a candidate getting double-digit
support in national polls for the
president and that person's name is not
Donald Trump or Hillary Clinton
necessarily that person's name is Gary
Johnson he's running for the Libertarian
Party presidential nomination he's in
Orlando Florida making the case to
voters right now Gary Johnson welcome to
Reason TV Matt great being with you
always
so you said after and you've said often
since your 2012 run as a libertarian
party candidate getting 1% of the vote
that that run itself was a failure yeah
and it was grueling and you can't get
elected president one person at a time I
don't say this to offend all the people
that worked really hard for me in 2012
but in retrospect 90% of the time I
spent running for president ended up to
be wasted time so what's different this
time around you doing having a 10%
that's that was successful doing that
and filling my time with that 10% and
part of that is having fun let's let's
reel back a little bit I've asked
everybody here including delegates and
this might be a little bit meta but
what's the purpose of a Libertarian
Party presidential campaign what is it
there for and how are you best
positioned to fulfill that purpose I
would not be doing this if there weren't
the opportunity to actually get elected
but to do that the only chance that a
third-party candidate has of getting
elected is to be in the presidential
debates the presidential debate
Commission says that you have to be at
15% in the polls
key for me right now is just being in
the polls I've been in three national
polls but for the three national polls
that I've been in I've witnessed another
30 national polls that have an
included my name if my name will just be
included in the polls I think that the
scrutiny that would go along with my
record and what it is that I'm saying
and hopefully my running mate bill welds
that if you put those resumes if you put
that job experience under the microscope
that it really holds up to very
successful Republican governors serving
in blue states fiscally conservative
socially liberal now you're talking as
if we're in a general election campaign
but we're not we're in Orlando Florida
to try to win a libertarian Yanni's
brightness and one of the critiques that
you hear out there in the floor a little
bit is that you're running the general
election campaign you gotta win the
primary first and the bill weld
nomination is not the right word right
it's a suggestion rule was received by
some people as hey they're already that
they're taking for granted that they're
gonna get the Libertarian Party thurr of
us are taking this for granted never
once have I said that I'm going to be
the nut libertarian nominee not once I
hope to be and bill welds same way never
once as he said or he hopes to be you
called him the original libertarian last
night got some boos for that for that
comment he's being critiqued as someone
who is just not quite libertarian enough
what is your response to that well that
bill weld was my role model in politics
when I say the original libertarian
actually when he talks about his history
going back to prosecuting Nixon and
Watergate he identified half the people
in the room as libertarian the other
half is a Republican he's always defined
himself philosophically as a libertarian
serving as governor of Massachusetts he
always described himself as the
Republican libertarian always took that
as a badge of honor Jesse Helms when
Jesse Helms denied bill weld
becoming ambassador to Mexico it was
because bill weld was pro-choice he was
Pro
gay rights he was pro medical marijuana
at a time when none of us were really
talking about those issues but he has
always talked about those issues walk us
through briefly the total idealized
scenario that starts so you get through
nomination you get your bill weld then
what happens that leads to the
breakthrough it's happening right now
it's happening I was on Jimmy Fallon
last night at night and I'm talking
second hand now I didn't see it but
Jimmy Fallon says hey there's a third
party candidate out there
it's Gary Johnson and then he runs a
clip with me talking about legalizing
marijuana cuts back to the crowd and
they're all cheering it's happening Matt
this is gonna make gifts of this with
the the Ron Paul hands here I asked you
this before you ran last time what's
failure this time what level beyond
which you don't go would be considered a
failure in this run assuming that you
get it I don't think it's failure I will
tell you what might not happen that will
lead to ultimately being failure and
that will be not being included in these
polls the difference this year and by
the way in 2012 the issue as I don't
think well I was not in one single
national poll I was in lesser polls and
I never had an issue with thresholds
when it comes to polling what I had an
issue with is gee I'm on the ballot in
enough states 48 in 2012 to
mathematically be elected president
shouldn't that entitle me to be at least
in the polls because I was only one of
four people that could have been elected
president the United States this
go-round okay three national polls to
this standpoint but as I pointed out
earlier they've been 30 national polls
that I've seen without my name in it
since during that same time period but
right now this is getting to critical
mass and so you talk about failure well
really there isn't failure at all in the
process but unsuccessful unsuccessful
will stem from not being in the polls
you